klima forschungsteams weltweit sind sich
einig die rückkehr von el niño steht
wohl kurz bevor das wetterphänomen hat
immer wieder auf ein neues verheerende
auswirkungen das auf der ganzen welt
sintflutartige regenfälle orkane und
flutkatastrophen nicht umsonst wird er
auch als biest godzilla oder monster
bezeichnet wie wahrscheinlich seine
rückkehr wirklich ist wann wir mit der
linie rechnen müssen und welche
auswirkungen er auch auf europa haben
wird dass er falls er jetzt bei klick
substanzen fiction herzlich willkommen
bei uns gibt's täglich seines videos und
zwar sehr spannende wenn er nichts
verpassen wollt dann abonniert den kanal
[Musik]
2015 und 2016 waren die letzten beiden
jahre in denen das wetterphänomen el
niño auf der erde gewütet hatte es gab
verheerende waldbrände beispielsweise in
indonesien überschwemmungen in paraguay
und ernteausfälle in südafrika und
indien und das sind nur einige wenige
beispiele der zahlreichen auswirkungen
die el niño damals zu verantworten hatte
doch auch in diesem winter 2018 2019
müssen wir uns wohl darauf gefasst
machen dass uns die gewaltigen stürme
eine chaotische wetterlage mit krassen
niederschlägen flutkatastrophen und
erdrutschen bescheren werden zerstörung
krankheiten und tod folgen den meist
genauso wie enorme wirtschaftliche
probleme in australien südasien
südafrika und mittel sowie südamerika
kommt es dann zu fatalen dürren in
anderen regionen der erde wie
beispielsweise dem östlichen nordpazifik
bedrohen wirbelstürme und überflutung
land und leute die aktuellen bedingungen
lassen sowohl die amerikanische
ozeanbehörde nok als auch das japanische
wetteramt sich sicher sein dass el niño
kurz bevorsteht die wahrscheinlichkeit
dafür dass dieses wetterphänomen im
kommenden winter auftritt wird mit 80
prozent angegeben konkret schließen die
fachleute dass aus den temperaturen im
östlichen und zentralen pazifik denn
wenn sich das wasser dort auf heitz ist
das ein klares zeichen dafür dass el
niño droht dort lag die temperatur in
der letzten woche bilanz ein grad über
dem langjährigen mittel
ab dem wert von 0,5 grad spricht man
tatsächlich von einem el niño wobei
dieser mindestens auf einer monatsbasis
überschritten werden mussten das genau
ist noch nicht überall der fall wobei
dies nicht wirklich als entwarnung zu
werten ist
in allen wichtigen regionen liegt die
temperatur über dem langjährigen
mittelwert der großteil der aktuellen
prognosen geht jetzt davon aus dass die
temperatur weiter erhöht bleibt und auch
die atmosphäre luft auf dieses warme
wasser reagieren wird und dies macht
einen el niño sehr wahrscheinlich doch
wie genau entsteht dieses wetterphänomen
eigentlich im normalfall sorgen die
passatwinde dafür dass das wasser
entlang des äquators im pazifik von
osten nach westen gedrückt wird denn die
passatwinde zirkulieren zwischen dem
tiefdruckgebiet vor der ostküste
australiens und dem hochdruckgebiet vor
der westküste südamerikas der jeweilige
druckausgleich bestimmt die
windgeschwindigkeiten die dabei
entstehen kalte und warme meeresströmung
kreisen übrigens parallel dazu wobei die
kalte meeresströmung aus dem süden als
humboldtstrom bezeichnet wird und für
ein ausgeglichenes klima im meer sorgt
bei einem el niño bricht das hoch
zusammen und zwar auf der südhalbkugel
zur weihnachtszeit deswegen bedeutet el
niño auch so viel wie christkind so
haben die peruanischen fischer dieses
wetterphänomen mal genannt für die
fischer dort bedeutet das eine riesige
katastrophe denn viele fische sterben
oder verlassen die region el niño ist
ein christkind das unglück bringt wenn
die passatwinde also bei einem el niño
zusammenbrechen blasen sie extrem stark
in entgegengesetzte richtung so
verändern sich auch die meeresströmungen
warme wasser massen bewegen sich von
ostasien aus zurück in richtung
südamerika
es sind wirklich gigantische mengen an
wasser die sich da durch den pazifik
bewegen und ihre wärme vor südamerika an
die luft dort abgeben der humboldtstrom
wird abgeleitet und durch die erwärmung
des meeres verenden die tiere in ihm und
das plankton auch doch nicht nur im
pazifikraum sorgt dieses wetterphänomen
unruhe und zerstörung denn auch die
passatwinde rund um den globus werden
dadurch beeinträchtigt somit gibt es
auch auswirkungen in europa der eisige
winter 2009 2010 beispielsweise ist nach
ansicht vieler fachleute eine folge von
el niño zu den ursachen des phänomens
wird weltweit noch geforscht doch es
gibt viele spekulationen
einige forschungsteams gehen davon aus
dass die sonneneruption einen
diese rolle spielen wir hatten ja schon
mal darüber berichtet hierbei ging es um
science-fiction alle vier jahre nämlich
verändert sich die intensität dieser
eruption quasi im el niño rhytmus das
phänomen tritt nämlich in unregelmäßigen
abständen von durchschnittlich vier
jahren auf deswegen wird spekuliert dass
die abgestrahlte energie der sonne
einfluss darauf nimmt das sieht man wie
empfindlich klima und wie in folge das
wetter hier auf der erde ist viele
experten und experten sehen aber auch
die globale erderwärmung als
verstärkenden faktor sie gehen davon aus
dass el niño deswegen zukünftig häufiger
auftreten wird dies zeigen einige
modelle zum beispiel untersuchungen des
kieler klimaforschers mojib latif
demnach werden sich die ereignisse
unter der globalen erwärmung
intensivieren falls sich das phänomen
weiter verstärken würde hätte dies nach
prognosen des kieler forschungsteams
auch für europäische regionen weit
reichende folgen dazu latif in einem
interview mit dem deutschlandfunk im
jahr 2015
sowohl nordeuropa als auch südeuropa
würden dann sehr stark auch unter den
einfluss des el niños geraten und wir
hätten dann beispielsweise extreme
trockenheit im mittelmeerraum
wir bleiben in diesem winter dran und
berichten hier weiter über die folgen
des christkinds wenn ihr kein video dazu
und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann abonniert auch den
englischen kanal
denn auch da gibt es immer wieder
videopremieren dafür einfach hier
draufklicken und da drunter geht's
weiter mit ice age in new york wurde
gulfstream kam touristenziel ich freue
mich euch auf euch auch auf dem
englischen kanal
stay tuned zu tun